Hi, welcome back. In this session, I'd
like to talk about extending approaches
we've used to value individual stocks,
intrinsic valuation or discounted cash
flow valuation or pricing and see if we
can use that to value and price the
market. Specifically, if you remember,
we said the value of an individual stock
in an intrinsic value world comes from
its cash flows, its growth, and its
risk. Now, that should apply for an
entire market as well, right? You could
value the market. Conversely, when we
looked at individual stocks, we talked
about comparing P ratios across stocks
and controlling for differences. What if
we can do that at the market level? You
could compare the market P today to
market P historically and not just stop
that. Control for differences in rates
and growth. Compare P ratios across
countries and look at not just countries
with low P ratios, but control for
differences across markets. in effect
were bringing to the entire market the
tools we used to decide whether
individual stocks were cheap or
expensive. So let's start with intrinsic
valuation. We'll start with the same
thesis. The value of an asset is the
present value of the expected cash flows
on the asset. But let's say the asset
we're talking about now is not an
individual company but the entire
market. To value the market, I need to
project out the expected cash flows I
will get from owning the entire market.
And to discount those cash flows, I need
a rate of return that I would demand for
investing in equities as a class
collectively. Expected cash flows
discounted back at that discount rate
should give me an intrinsic valuation
the market. You ready? Let's try this
out. On January 1st, 2025, the S&P 500
was trading at 58.881.63.
Now, the that that index is composed of
the 500 largest market cap stocks in the
US. If you'd bought all 500 companies in
the year leading up to the start of
2025, the dividends on that index would
have been 73.40 in index units. What
does that mean? Well, the index is not
in billions or millions. It's scaled to
index units. So, I've taken the
dividends in billions or millions and
converted them into index units.
Now, that 73.4 is about a third was less
than a third of the earnings that year.
So, here's where we are. We know the
level of the index. We know the
dividends you'd have received by owning
all 500 stocks. Let's assume you go with
the simplest intrinsic valuation model
you can have for valing equity. The
dividend discount model. You could
project out the expected dividends from
buying the S&P 500. You'd start with the
73.40 that you had dividend as dividends
last year. And if you assume that
dividends grow with earnings and
analysts are expecting a growth rate of
9.57%
a year for the next 5 years, you can get
the projected dividends for the next 5
years. That gives me my expected
dividends from owning the stock for the
next 5 years. You're saying what
happened the end of the fifth year? The
dividends continue to grow but now at a
much lower rate at a rate let's say
equal to the risk-free rate. The
risk-free rate is 4.58%.
So you have 9.57% growth for the next 5
years, 4.58% thereafter. I get expected
dividends for the next 5 years and
beyond. Now to discount those dividends,
I need a cost of equity for the entire
market. And in many ways, estimating an
expected return for the entire market is
easier than estimating the expected
return for an individual stock. You
start with a risk-free rate. In this
case, let's assume the T-bond rate is
risk-free. And there can be questions
about that. 4.58%.
And to that, let's add an equity risk
premium 4 a.5%. You say, where did that
come from? Well, you can look at
history, you can look at your own gut
and say, this is what I can settle for
as an acceptable premium. That's my cost
of equity, 9.08%.
I discount my expected dividends for the
next 5 years at that 9.08%.
At the end of the fifth year though,
since stocks continue in perpetuity, I
let the dividends grow at the risk-free
rate 4.58%.
And treat it as a perpetuity, a growing
perpetuity. If you don't remember the
equation for a growing perpetuity,
review the session on valuation. That
last term is my terminal value for the
index. I discount it back to today. The
present value that I get for just
dividends is 279.
If you remember, stocks were priced at
5850. This would suggest that stocks are
massively overvalued by more than 70%.
Now, before you get too upset or
anxious, this is focusing just on
dividends. If you remember in an earlier
session, we talked about dividends. We
also talked about how US stocks in
particular have increasingly shifted
away from dividends to buying back
stock. Your cash flows are now taking
the form if you own the entire index not
just in dividends but in stock buybacks.
That cash cash flow if you add back the
buybacks is much higher than the base
dividends you received 182.79 in the
trailing 12 months. And if you let that
collective cash flow that includes
buybacks grow at the growth rate that
analysts are projecting, you get much
higher cash flows for the next 5 years.
And using the same approach we used in
the dividend discount model, if you
assume a perpetuity after year five
growing at 4.58% a year, the present
value of this this aggregated or summed
up cash flow is 5,098.
Markets are still coming out as
overvalued, but by a more reasonable
amount, 15%.
On an intrinsic value basis, you would
conclude stocks are overvalued by 15% at
the start of 2025. You think this is
neat? Why don't we do this to decide
whether to be in markets or not? Well,
when you look at intrinsic valuation
models, they tend to work, but they tend
to work over the long term. In other
words, if you find stocks to be
undervalued using an intrinsic value
model, there's no guarantee it'll
correct the next year. It might not even
correct over the next 5 years. It might
do it over the next 10 years. And
there's a there's a cost you face
because you're not sure about the
timing. Let's say you did an intrinsic
valuation of the S&P 500 in 2014
and you concluded stocks are overvalued.
So what do you do? you sell all stocks
because you don't own overvalued stuff.
You know what? You'd have been out of
stocks probably for the next 8 years.
You're going to be out of the market
while you're waiting for the market to
correct. And this becomes the question
is the benefit of getting it right
enough to cover the cost of being out of
the market for extended periods. There's
also the problem with intrinsic
valuation models that there might be a
structural shift going on where people's
risk premiums are coming down where
growth is going up or companies are
becoming more efficient, you haven't
captured it in your numbers. So
intrinsic valuation models are tricky to
use in timing markets because even
though they might be right in the long
term, a long-term might be a long it
might take enough of your portfolio that
you're you you're trapped in cash while
you wait for that correction to happen.
So intrinsic valuation, let's move on to
pricing. In pricing, you look at what
stocks are priced at and you compare
them either to their own history or to
other markets. You could argue that
pricing is is a le a lot more flexible
than intrinsic valuation because you
don't have the assumptions about cash
flows and discount rates you need in the
context of pricing. There are two ways
you will see pricing used in market
timing. One is to compare the pricing of
stocks today to the pricing
historically. We started on this in the
mean reversion discussion the last
session but here we're going to dig a
little deeper or comparing the PE ratios
across different markets. But the key
when you're pricing is you control for
changes over time. So here's what I'd
like to do. I'd like to go back to a
chart we've looked at already where we
looked at PE ratios across time in the
last session, but there we talked in the
context of mean reversion. Here I've
inverted the PE ratio and pre presented
as an earnings to price ratio. That's
that's the that's the blue line you see
there, the earnings yield. I've
superimposed the T-bond rate each year.
And if I just stopped there and I showed
you those two lines and I asked you, do
the two move together? Your answer is,
of course, they do. And that should come
as no surprise. When rates are high,
stocks are priced lower. When stocks are
priced lower, the earnings to price
ratio is higher. And when rates are low,
stocks are priced higher and the
earnings to price ratio decreases.
You're saying, "So what?" Now, if I if
you're a believer in mean reversion,
you'd stop here. And in fact, we saw
people use the Fed model where they
compare the earnings to price ratio to
the T- bond rate. I'm going to dig a
little deeper here. I'm going to also
bring in the difference between the T-
bond rate and the table rate into this
as in that in the columns. What does
this capture the slope of the yield
curve? Now, let's bring some statistics
into play. What am I trying to do? So
I'm trying to explain the changes in
earnings to price ratios across time
using the level of rates and the slope
of the yield curve. And the first step I
do is I do a correlation between the
earnings yield and the T- bond rate.
What do I discover? The two move
together. No surprise, right? You saw
the graph. And historically when the T-
bond rate is much higher than the table
rate, the slope of the yield curve has
mattered. And there the relationship is
negative. The more downward sloping or
flat or downward sloping the yield
curve, the worse it is for stocks.
Now, that's a correlation by itself.
Correlations are tough to trade on. So,
I've taken that correlation and run a
regression of the earnings to price
ratio against the T- bond rate and the
difference in the T- bond rate and the
table rate using 1960 to 2024 data.
Here's what I find. Every 1% increase in
the T- bond rate increases the earnings
to price ratio by 0.56%.
It's kind of messy because earnings to
price ratios are inverted P ratio. So
when earnings to price ratios go up, P
ratios go down. So as T- bond rates go
up, price earnings ratios decrease.
I threw in the T- bond rate and the
T-OLE rate and the relationship is
negative. As the T- bond rate becomes
higher relative to the T- bond rate, my
earnings to price ratio decreases. In
other words, PE ratios tend to be lower
with flat or negative yield curves. But
before you get too excited, notice that
the t statistics measuring significance
is close to zero. The yield curve no
longer seems to have any explanatory
power in explaining PE ratios. You're
saying no longer or what are we talking
about? If you go back to 2008, you ran
the same regression. Then the T-bond
rate minus the Tel rate yield curves had
a much stronger explanatory power before
2008.
Something has happened in the last 15 to
20 years where the link between the
yield curve and stock prices seems to
have broken down. There is actually this
rule of thumb that people use on Wall
Street. When the yield curve becomes
downward sloping, it's bad for stocks.
That might have been true in 2000 and
1999 or 1985. It is no longer true
today. You're saying how does this help
me time markets? If you plug in today's
T- bond rate and today's table rate into
this regression, you get a predicted
earnings to price ratio today. I'll tell
you what it worked out for me. It worked
out to be about 5%. What does that tell
me? Given the level of rates and the and
the tel rate but t-bond and t-old rates
today
the earnings to price ratio should be 5%
which translates into a PE ratio of 20.
If you remember the PE ratio today is
about 23 to 24 on a pricing basis after
controlling for the level of rates
stocks are still overpriced. So that's
pricing playing out by comparing across
time.
You can also compare markets
geographically, right? This is for
instance P ratio the the countries with
the lowest PE ratios the start of 2025.
Now if you are a naive investor and you
said lower P ratios mean stocks are
cheaper. I'm going to put my money in
these countries. Take a look at this
list of countries and ask yourself
whether you want your portfolio in a
sense invested almost entirely in these
countries. Notice what they have in
common.
Most of them are incredibly risky,
illlquid markets. Already you can see
why PE ratios will vary across
countries. Riskier countries, PE ratios
will be lower than safer countries.
Unless you control for those
differences, you're going to end up
putting your money into countries that
you think are cheap but deserve to be
cheap. So, how can we control for them?
I'm going to go back to a very old
example because it kind of illustrates
the process really well. In June of
2000, I collected the PE ratios for a
bunch of markets which at that time are
classified as emerging markets.
So you have the PE ratio in the in the
second column. You look just at PE
ratio. It's a no-brainer, right? Turkey
is the cheapest market followed by
Argentina. But I collected three pieces
of data on each country. the level of
interest rates in that country, the real
GDP growth of that country, capturing
high growth versus low growth, and a
measure of country risk, but the higher
this number, the riskier the country.
And here's my prior. Riskier countries
should trade lower P ratios in safer
countries. Countries with higher growth
should trade at higher P ratios than
countries with low growth. And countries
with high interest rates should trade at
lower P ratios. Intuitively, you can see
why. saying, "How does it help me decide
where to put my money?" Again, I went
back to my statistics class and I looked
up the chapter in multiple regressions.
What am I trying to explain? Differences
in PE ratios across countries. That's my
dependent variable. What are the three
variables that I think affect PE ratios?
The level of rates, the growth in GDP,
and country risk. First, notice the
signs are consistent. Higher interest
rates, lower PE. Higher growth, higher
P. Higher country risk, lower P. I got
lucky. That doesn't always work out with
the data. I'm getting consistent
relationships. The R squ is not bad.
It's a small samples. I'm going to take
it with a grain of salt. But I can use
this regression to get predicted PS for
each country. You're saying, what are
you talking about? Let's take Turkey,
right? I could take the level of rates,
the GDP, real growth, and country risk.
Go back to the regression, plug in
Turkeykey's numbers in, get a predicted
P. I get a predicted P of 13.35.
Much lower than my predicted P for Hong
Kong or for uh or for Mexico, but still
higher than the P that Turkey is trading
at. Turkey looks cheap even after I
control for the high interest rates, the
low growth, and the high country risk.
And that's the advantage of being able
to control for differences. Now, you
might not be comfortable with
statistics. You might not like running
regression. That's perfectly okay. You
can still ask those questions, right?
Because when you compare PE ratios
across countries and you see a country
with a low PE ratio before you jump in,
you might want to at least check for
high interest rates and low growth and
high risk because that might explain
that PE ratio.
So if you think about using fundamentals
either in their intrinsic value form or
in their pricing form,
remember that there there are
limitations. One is you're looking at
the past to make a judgment about the
future. And to the extent that there's
been a shift in that relationship,
you're not going to catch it. And if you
want to improve your odds of success,
you want to get creative about capturing
those variables that might explain the
ship. So I'll give you an example. Let's
assume the reason you think the link
between yield curves
and stock prices has has dro that link
has become much weaker after 2008 and
you think the reason is because of
passive investing. I don't think it is,
but let's say you do that the amount of
money going to index funds is what you
can actually look at the percentage of
money in the market that is in index
funds. Throw that into your regression
as a variable and that might explain the
the shift and that means you're no
longer talking about something after the
fact. You're bringing it to the
analysis. And with both intrinsic
valuation and pricing, assuming you make
a judgment, you have trust in that
judgment. you want to buy or sell based
on that. The longer your time horizon,
the greater your chance of success.
I hope you found the session useful and
I thank you very much for listening.